the space station when no one was aboard
that was expedition one
and the crew can operate the uh hatches
from their modules so they um
they when they dock it's it's not
requiring anybody aboard the
international space station
to take any actions now we do watch
the incoming vehicles as a precaution
however
uh the vehicle can dock autonomously on
its own so
the expedition one crew members were
able to enter the space station and
began our 20 years of continuous human
presence
next question is what are the astronauts
on the international space station sleep
schedules like
ah that's a that's a really great
question because we know that
uh their schedules are very uh
meticulous down to
the five minutes it's planned out is
that correct absolutely
and their sleep periods uh look kind of
similar to ours
they get a little bit of time before bed
to wind down and then they get about an
eight and a half hour period of sleep
time
and then afterward they have a pre-sleep
time period as well so they get to
wake up a little bit before starting an
incredibly busy day
almost every day so that's like what
their sleep schedule
is dragon spacex for approach initiation
yes your updated ai time is
022
and with that that is approximately one
five minutes earlier than what we were
predicting pre-flight
so that will we expect to move your suit
dawning time frame about
one five minutes earlier as well and
we'll call you into that at the
appropriate time
okay happy zero two two two fifteen
minutes early and
also moves up down in 15 minutes thanks
for the heads up
good
morning here in hawthorne the crew
operations and resources engineer
to the crew aboard the international
space station
sharing that that approach initiation
burn which is the next major burn we're
looking for
that should come at about 6 22
pm pacific time so about an hour from
now just over
an hour from now and that also moves up
their suit donning time so they'll start
putting their suits on about 15 minutes
earlier than they expected
looking forward to that and in the
meantime we have another question
have you and any mission controls
not yet have we slept have you slept yet
i got in a few hours last night but to
be honest it's
almost too exciting to sleep right now
right um
and so fortunately we do work in shifts
and so mission controllers flight
controllers in houston
and in hawthorne do get the chance to
get some rest we don't want anybody
working for
24 hours straight which the crew has now
been in orbit
for uh 24 hours now and so
uh they only work about eight or nine
hours of shift in mission control that
keeps everybody
fresh and uh making their best decisions
yeah that's very important with
very stringent missions like this that
have a lot going on
it's very important that everybody you
know has their rest and is thinking
very clearly um during these phases have
you slept yet though
i tried i was too excited last night
i got a little bit of rest but all very
exciting so
i i don't mind yeah it's the best kind
of nostalgic
right this question if nasa launches
another
resupply ship to the international space
station where will it dock
well there's a little bit of a
difference between docking and
birthing we have two places where
spacecraft can dock on the international
space station
that's those international docking
adapters and docking means the
spacecraft can fly in
and attach itself to the station it
doesn't really need any
specific help from the crew on board
there are also two stations where a
spacecraft can be
birthed to the station this says when we
use the canada arm 2 or a crew member he
uses cannon arm 2
in the cupola reaches out and grapples
the spacecraft or gets a good grasp in
it
on it before bringing it to the space
station
they then turn the controls over to
teams on the ground and teams on the
ground
birth it or attach it to the space
station so
there are still some uh open spaces for
or i should say maybe parking spots
parking spots on the space station
and there are also four spots that
vehicles can dock on the russian segment
as well
how do astronauts get haircuts
while they're in space that is a very
interesting question
how do they do it it's one of those
things that you just don't think about
too often
but everybody needs a haircut sometimes
and they learn to cut each other's hair
so
yes they do before they fly they learn
how to cut one another's hair
and for the men who have short hair they
can use
sort of like a razor but it has a vacuum
attached to it
so that there's some suction and there's
not tiny pieces of hair flowing
everywhere because you
don't want to get one of those in your
eye yeah
so it's a little bit easier to catch
those if they can get them right
whenever they're clipped
so they learn how to cut hair uh they
cut each other's hair
they all become barbers it's another job
of an astronaut
so many skills you have to learn to be
an astronaut but it actually sounds kind
of fun
i don't trust myself
so coming up we are expecting that
approach initiation burn having
completed those other five major burns
and these burns are what propel us
toward the international space station
getting closer and closer let's take a
look at the data
right now crew dragon is 26 kilometers
away
from the international space station and
uh
we will be expecting that burn to come
up at about 6
22 pacific time
and to put that in miles we said 20
25 kilometers 26 that's 16.1
miles from the space station so we
should be able to start getting some
pretty cool views of crew dragon
as well from the station looking forward
to that
so just as a reminder we did complete
five major burns on dragon that is the
phase burn uh if you're following along
on the screen that's the phase burn
the closed calyptic burn then the
transfer burn
followed by the close the final coalitic
burn
and now we are entering into the
approach burn
which will swing dragon up in front of
the international space station
as you can kind of see on that graphic
and then there's a number of checkpoints
that the vehicle will be
checking in as it gets closer and closer
to the space station prior to the soft
capture
and hard capture of the dragon to the
station
and so far we have seen the completion
of those burns like you talked about
those use a combination of the thrusters
on dragon
being the service section thrusters
around dragon itself
additionally those forward bulkhead
thrusters under the nose cone
a combination of those are used for
those burns and now we have
some more to look forward to one is the
approach
out of plane burn this can be skipped by
dragon if we realize that uh we don't
necessarily
need the burn and the uh the vehicle
decides that for itself it knows exactly
where it is in space
that would be coming up at 5 30 p.m
pacific time we'll see if it's necessary
and then at 605 pm pacific time we'll be
looking for the go no go
for the approach initiation burn this
really sets us on course to link up or
to get even closer to the space station
that approach initiation burn would be
at 6 30 p.m pacific time so about an
hour and 10 minutes from now
and that would be about a 90-second burn
there may also be an approach initiation
mid-course burn and this is a
fine-tuning maneuver another one that
crew dragon makes the determination of
what it really needs it might need a
small burn it might need a significant
burn
to put it exactly where we want to be on
approach to the international space
station
at 7 05 pm pacific we'll be looking for
the go
no go to approach to waypoint one
now waypoint one moves dragon directly
in front of the station it's about 220
meters away at this point
and it's directly in front of its
docking port uh that's the node two
forward port
before we go to waypoint one we need to
get that poll
but we'll actually be around waypoint
zero that's 400 meters below
and that occurs at 7 15 pm pacific time
at 7 29 pm pacific time we will have a
go no go to
approach waypoint 2 and this is when
we're getting really close to the
international space station
waypoint 2 is only 20 meters from the
station
and dragon will focus on aligning its
docking system with the international
docking adapter
it'll take about five minutes from
dragon to get from
waypoint two to the international space
station so
it's a short journey but uh from that 20
meter mark just about five minutes
and just before crew dragon docks with
the international space station we might
hear a call
out we will hear the call out chop
that's crew hands off point
that would be coming at 7 59 in 35
seconds pm pacific time
it's very specific right now because
that's about two meters
before contact and uh we're looking for
contact and capture of dragon
dragon spacex dragon is seven minutes
from an out of plane burn
i've admitted to the airplane thanks
and we are also less than 2.5 hours from
the earliest stocking time
we copy less than 2.5 to earliest
docking thank you
getting really close and they took the
words right out of my mouth
uh we'll be looking for contact and
capture around 8pm
pacific time so we'll be standing by for
that
and then docking will be complete once
those hard hooks have finished driving
or giving us hard capture i should say
around 8 13 p.m pacific time and those
are variable times
but we also heard that we are expecting
an
approach out of plane burn coming up
shortly
the cpu dragon's computer has determined
that
that will be necessary just to put them
on the proper path
as we continue our journey toward the
international space station so
stay tuned with us we are covering every
step of dragon's journey
so
so
dragon spacex
dragon copy
and with that call we know the oop burn
or the out of plane
burn is complete uh that was a
tentative burn we didn't necessarily
know if we would need it once we got on
orbit or not
but crew dragon is a very smart vehicle
and
it can make that call on its own it
constantly knows where the international
space station is
and its own place and space so it's not
necessarily uh
programmed in by the flight controllers
here on the ground or punched in by the
crew on orbit
but the vehicle puts it in the exact
place it needs to be
for the upcoming approach initiation
burn that will be at 6
22 pm pacific time
so
got some really cool views here on your
left hand screen is station
looking at dragon that very bright spot
on the screen
but on your right hand screen that is
dragon
looking at the station yeah so really
cool views of them
looking at each other they're close
enough where they can see each other
both in sight now yeah getting their
first
glimpse of each other i guess we've been
able to see a few views
of crew dragon from the station space
station before now
but the first time that we've seen
station from crew dragon so getting
ever closer and we're looking about two
and a half hours away from docking now
uh crew dragon is currently 15 miles
away
from the international space station
and status
we have already gone external with
cameras please just let us know when we
can come back
on board additionally reminder to
power off and clean your displays using
your comfort garment
then power back on as a part of your
suit donning
also due to the iss sleep period
we plan to delay the big loop
configuration and com checks a bit
now planning this for approximately zero
two
zero zero utc finally
we are expecting an extended period of
ratty calm on tetris
from one five six utc
208 utc how comfy
okay we copy we're not gonna
configure for uh the big loop until
zero two i think you said two two
zero two here go for 4.010 suit donning
and audio configuration we'll let you
know when you can come back on board and
copy
on ratty tdrs and the big loop com time
is 0
200 utc
okay 0-200 for big loop
we are just over two hours from docking
and the crew is getting ready to get
back into their spacesuits for the
rendezvous and docking
and uh we'll be looking for a integrated
operations to begin
spacex flight controllers closely
coordinating maneuvers
with the teams in houston the ground
controllers initiate and monitor the
preparations for the approach
including establishing communications
with the station and
initializing the spacecraft's navigation
sensors to prepare for autonomous
docking now we're getting very close to
getting the go ahead for approach
during the approach space spacex flight
controllers will work in tandem with
nasa with the nasa team in houston
to activate and test out a number of
systems on dragon
including bi-directional communications
with the station using the c2v2 system
which stands for common communications
for visiting vehicles
and sets up the data stream from dragon
to the station giving another path for
dragon telemetry to come
to the ground and giving an additional
command capability to astronauts aboard
the station
they'll also maneuver dragon to the
proper attitude and initialize the
navigation sensors
used for the methodical approach to
station
we are in those integrated operations so
teams working together and the next
call outs we hope to hear will be at the
top of the hour
i'll be looking for big loop
communications we've heard that a couple
of times from the core
that refers to communications with the
space station from the crew dragon
spacecraft
those vehicles being able to share
telemetry and communications with each
other
and we want to we want to hold on that a
little bit because the
crew aboard the international space
station is actually still asleep right
now
now we don't want to wake them up just
yet if we don't have to so those will be
the next uh the next comps we will
probably hear
and then afterward we'll be looking for
that approach initiation burn
coming up at about 6 22 pm pacific time
[Music]
so
so
hi everyone thanks for joining us for
this live coverage of crew dragon on its
way to the international space station
with the crew one crew and you're
getting views of both of those vehicles
right now
on your left hand side is a view of
crude dragon
from the space station and on your right
hand side is a view
of the space station from crew dragon so
getting a look at each other as they get
closer and closer
they are now in the approach initiation
phase having left that rendezvous phase
behind
whenever they reach 30 kilometers away
from the
international space station and we are
still answering your questions with the
hashtag
ask nasa as we wait for some upcoming
approach milestones the next
big one of those being the approach
initiation burn
at 6 22 pm pacific
but this first question is what is the
pressure difference between
dragon and the international space
station
the pressure in the vehicles should be
similar somewhat similar we're looking
at about 14.2
psi on the station right now and to put
that into perspective
14.7 is about what we're used to at sea
level on earth
so we try and keep that atmosphere
similar it can vary uh
by a few tenths of a degree
got another question can the astronauts
smell
and taste normally in space
huh yeah you wouldn't uh it's not the
first thing you think about maybe being
altered by
space exploration but the astronaut
sense of smell
is slightly altered once they arrive at
the station and that makes
tasting a little bit more difficult as
well so i know they like being able to
put
spices on their foods hot sauce things
like that
so that way it makes them just a little
bit stronger because they do
lose a little bit of that sense of smell
once they arrive
got another question since the spacex
suits are not eva suits designed for
outside the station
which space suits would they be wearing
for outside
so good point these are very different
suits these
spacex suits are meant to be worn inside
and as jesse mentioned they are
really meant for any sort of
depressurization of the cabin
which we never plan for but that is why
we wear them
uh we have eva suits as you mentioned
for
trips outside eva is extra vehicular
activity or
spacewalk these are those bigger white
suits you're used to they're a little
bit harder to move around in
but they have many layers of protection
against the vacuum of space
and of course the varying temperatures
experienced in space as well
got another question how come you can't
see stars from the international space
station but on earth we can look up
and see the stars so actually you can
see stars from the international space
station i think even in those views that
we were showing earlier
looking at dragon you could see the
stars from the space station but looking
at the station
we got a lot of sun beaming into the
camera so
it was really hard to see uh the stars
in the background but
you can still see the stars probably
even better out in space
yeah because you're really not exposed
to as much light pollution
on the international space station
highly encourage you to go follow the
space station on twitter facebook
instagram because sometimes the
astronauts take beautiful photos of the
earth at night they can see the aurora
borealis
and the stars in the milky way sometimes
it's
pretty amazing another question do the
solar panels produce enough energy for
the international space station or do
they have to rely
on another source for power if so what
is that source
the solar panels are massive on the
international space station
and so they do collect all of the energy
that we use on board
but what happens when we go into the
dark so when we go into the dark uh
when we're in the light the
international space station is using
those solar panels
and channeling some of that energy
through a bcdu that's a battery charge
discharge unit so there are some
batteries that hold that power
and then when we're in the dark that
battery charge
the ground is go for approach initiation
we will be enabling the maneuver shortly
the expected maneuver
start time is 0 2
2 2 utc
okay we copy go for the approach
initiation
zero two two two utc
great news there from the core to the
crew
uh there was a poll conducted here and
the team
was go for the approach initiation burn
likewise now that we're in integrated
operations
a poll was also conducted in houston and
they are go for the approach initiation
burn as well
and confirming that 6 22 pm pacific
time uh is when that burn should begin
we've got another question how long can
astronauts stay
at the international space station and
in space mrs reed's
eighth grade science class is wondering
that's a good question and so far we've
had an astronaut stay
almost a full year on the international
space station we actually had a couple
an astronaut and a cosmonaut back in
2015
spent almost an entire year on the
international space station
uh the longest day ever was valerie
kolyakov poliakov for 437 days on space
station mir
so that's the record but we do these
long duration stays because you know our
future goal is to go on even longer
duration missions to the moon and to
mars and so that's going to require us
to really understand how the human body
adapts to microgravity
that's a that's a long time a little
over a year yeah
and crew one is going to be there for
six months so less than half of that
but still a long time they'll build up
their tolerance to get there
this question from brantley could dragon
be manually docked
yes uh dragon was designed to be
autonomous
but it was also designed in case of any
emergency
or any necessity uh that the crew
on board can manually dock if needed and
they do
all that training here in hawthorne in
the crew training room
you know they practice docking just in
case but
it is autonomous so in the best scenario
they don't have to manually dock
and
so
so
turn station on two for the status
okay just wanted to give you a heads up
we're about eight minutes ahead on the
timeline and we will be configuring the
big loop shortly so you will have a
connection with dragon here in a few
minutes
okay copy on the big loop and that'll be
on two correct that's correct we'll do
comm checks onto
all right
dragon species
dragon the ground go ahead
the 144k bi-directional link has been
established
please change your push-to-talk
destination to iss
and then initiate a comm check
[Music]
dragging copies and words
dragon spacex i hear you loud and clear
help me
and i've got you loud and clear as well
great to hear please initiate a contract
with iss to confirm that path thank you
roger that's okay uh station uh this is
dragon crown check on the big loop
and he sensation this is kate i heard
you but i have not heard dragon yet
oh what a good voice to hear dragon this
is station i've got you unclear
[Applause]
hey it's good to hear your voice as well
pilot suite contract
great news there from crew dragon and
the international space station
both now have communications with one
another we heard the excitement
in kate rubin's voice getting that comm
check with commander mike hopkins
so we're gonna check in with brandy over
in mission control houston
how's it going over there brandi
things are good over here thanks so much
yeah as you heard kate rubens is awake
now and jumping straight into her day
and now that she's got those comm checks
done the first thing that she'll be
doing is closing the shutters on the
cupola to keep
the windows protected from any
contamination that might occur during
the dragon's approach
she can open them up for a look if she
needs to but primarily she'll be using
computers inside the cupola to monitor
the dragon as it comes in closer to the
international space station for docking
she'll be just making sure that it's
where it's supposed to be at all times
as it does uh
get closer and closer over the course of
the night her work will really pick up
though
after docking that's when it's time to
open the space station
side of the hatch and she's got a lot of
work to do for that um
i do want to warn you that the hatch
opening won't take place right away
after docking there are
quite a number of steps that we have to
go through to get
those two crews all on the same side of
the hatch
first rubens will start by opening the
hatch between the harmony node and the
pressurized mating adapter that's a kind
of a short tunnel
that connects the harmony node to the
international
docking adapter which is what's going to
allow the dragon to dock to the
international space station
but before that hatch is open the small
space between the station side and the
dragon side has to be pressurized you'll
hear that called the vestibule over the
course of the night
up until docking it will have been
exposed to the vacuum of space so they
need to fill it up with air and make
sure
the air pressure matches that on
the other sides of those those two
hatches the space station and the dragon
so that takes a little while but in the
meantime we are growing ever closer to
being
able to see all members of the dragon
crew
joining the expedition 64 crew onboard
the international space station
getting a little closer so i'll throw it
back now to hogwarts so they can give
you an update on the approach initiation
burn as we wait
thanks brandi great to hear from you and
great to hear that things are going well
on the international space station side
we copy that that uh that docking to
hatch opening time will take a couple of
hours
and we will be here for every single
second of it
coming up next we will be looking for
the approach initiation burn
and that should come around 6 22 p.m
pacific time
so
so what you can see on your screen is
the astronauts getting suited up and
strapped into their seats they're
preparing for that initiation
uh approach initiation burn um
looks like they're almost ready yeah
we're getting really close now
and that'll be scheduled actually from a
minute from now
6 22 pm pacific time we'll be looking
for that burn to occur
it should be about a minute and a half
long
and that will uh the thrusters will fire
on dragon to
it'll it's currently about 2.5
kilometers below station and this will
swing dragon up until it's about
400 meters or a quarter mile directly
below the station
this maneuver will also move dragon
inside of one of those two checkpoints
around the station that requires a set
of go no go pulls
with the different control teams the
first checkpoint is
called the approach ellipsoid or
as you might hear it called the ae it's
an imaginary shape measuring four by two
by two kilometers essentially a large
three-dimensional
oval before dragon is given permission
to move
inside the approach ellipsoid the
capsule is configured to be on what is
known
as a 24-hour safe trajectory this means
that if dragon lost all control through
to its thrusters it would be at least 24
hours before its trajectory
would move inside the approach ellipsoid
so that go for the approach initiation
burn was also the go for moving in
that's
inside that approach ellipsoid and that
means things are all checking out well
on dragon
we are standing by listening for that
call that the approach initiation burn
has begun
currently looking about an hour and 40
minutes from docking
and the burn has begun as we mentioned
looking at around 90 seconds for this
burn and an amazing photo here or video
i should say
of the international space station from
crude dragon becoming
ever clearer as it gets closer yeah you
can really see it now before it looked
kind of just like a bright light now you
can kind of see the shape
of the station there
a reminder that approach initiation burn
currently underway
and even baby yoda's ready for it
one minute 15 seconds into the approach
initiation burn
dragon spacex on the big loop burn
complete
nominal burn and reminder to review your
impulsive retreat recovery cue cards if
desired
okay dragon copies and we saw a good
burn
and reviewed the cue cards winning
station copies thanks
[Music]
that concludes the approach initiation
burn about
90-second burn
and communications from crew dragon and
the international space station letting
them know
they can review some back away
procedures if need be
however everything's still proceeding
nominally with crew dragon just
completing that approach initiation burn
that brings them up to the 400 meter
below station point
next burn coming up is the approach
initiation mid-course burn that should
be about
6 55 pm pacific time
that's another one of those fine-tuning
maneuvers uh and dragon's computer will
determine
what is necessary for that burn
just to keep it on track moving in uh
even closer to the international space
station
again what you're looking at on your
screen is a view from
dragon looking at the international
space station
we're now under seven kilometers away
from the international space station a
little over 23 minutes to that
approach initiation mid-course burn and
should arrive at waypoint zero
at 400 meters below station in just
42 minutes that's the first checkpoint
the vehicle can hold there
or it can continue if all systems check
out
we'll do a go no go to approach to
waypoint one
before we arrive at waypoint zero
because as i mentioned
uh waypoint zero is not necessarily a
hold point if everything is still
looking good
so we'll also be looking to hear that uh
that go
for waypoint one and waypoint one is
what moves
where when dragon moves directly in
front of the station it'll be about 220
meters away at that point
and directly in front of its docking
port which is the no
two forward port
what you're seeing is a live view inside
of the capsule with the crew
checking out their display panels right
in front of them
as a reminder all of these burns are
happening uh
autonomously the crew is simply
monitoring as you said using those
display panels
they're not controlling crew dragon at
this point they do
have the option to do so if they needed
to
but as we mentioned the vehicle has been
performing well and putting us right on
track where we need to be
makes their ride pretty easy
again just as a reminder what you're
looking at is a view
inside of the capsule on your left side
is mike hopkins
and on your right is victor glover
this is a view inside hawthorne mission
control where flight controllers are
monitoring all the systems
aboard crew dragon and as we mentioned
earlier we are now in
integrated operations meaning there's a
whole other control room and play and
that's mission control houston
view right here they are monitoring
everything aboard the international
space station they're both conducting
these polls that we're mentioning
because we are in integrated operations
we want to make sure both sides are go
before we move crew dragon closer to the
international space station we've gotten
all goes for all of those polls tonight
so far
the next poll coming up should be for
waypoint
one
go ahead
and sorry kate uh that was for spacex
we're getting ready to start our state
league
[Music]
and this view coming to you live from
crew dragon this
is a view of the international space
station
from the crew dragon vehicle as crew one
continues to make their way to the
station
they launched at 7 27 pm eastern time
yesterday have completed the five major
burns
exited the rendezvous phase and are now
approaching the space station we're
looking at
docking coming up in about an hour and
15 minutes potentially
and that's a flexible time and we before
that though
have an approach initiation mid-course
burn that should be in about
four minutes from now about 14 minutes
from now
the teams will do a go no go for the
vehicle to move to
waypoint zero that is 400 meters below
the international space station
afterward they will do they go no go to
approach waypoint
two uh that's coming up at 7 29 p.m
pacific and waypoint 2
is when the vehicle is just 20 meters
away from the international space
station so that's the last hold point
for the vehicle
and then after way point zero uh
they will approach even closer do a go
no go pull
for docking and then after
that go no go pull will be when they
depart from way point two
and then do a crew hands off point check
and then initiate contact which will be
first a
soft capture um followed by a
hard capture uh completing docking
yeah and that uh crew hands off point is
a reminder to the crew it's just a call
from the teams here to the ground
it's a reminder to the crew to if they
are maneuvering the vehicle in any way
obviously they're not or they shouldn't
be because it's autonomous
but to not maneuver the vehicle anymore
it comes about
when crew dragons about two meters away
from the docking port just before that
soft
capture so we're looking at about two
minutes and 40 seconds
now until that mid-course maneuver crew
dragon will execute the burn
putting it exactly where it needs to be
to begin
the next step of the approached sequence
we also heard recently the crew as you
saw earlier were in their suits
and they'll be in their suits until
after docking we
heard that they had four good suit leak
checks
so that's always good news coming from
the crew
and we are standing by for that next uh
that next burn the mid-course maneuver
i mean we've got confirmation that the
approach initiation mid-course burn
has begun we are standing by
uh for the timing on that burn but that
did happen
on time and once it's complete the next
milestone we'll be looking for is the go
no go pole
for the uh approach to waypoint zero
just standing by for the confirmation
for that
approach initiation mid course burn
which has already begun
and once this burn is complete as we
mentioned we'll have the go no go for
waypoint zero
that will put us about 400 meters below
station once we reach it this is the
first checkpoint
the vehicle doesn't have to hold here it
can continue on if all the systems
check out and once it continues on it
will go to waypoint
one dragon spacex on
the big loop burn complete nominal burn
the trajectory has converged on waypoint
zero
and dragon copies good burn and
conversion on waypoint zero goodness
good news for a good burn and that will
put us
in line with where we need to be for
waypoint zero 400 meters below the
station
we will also move to waypoint one
shortly after that's where dragon moves
in front of the station approximately
220 meters away
and directly in front of the docking
port the node 2
forward port
they'll also need to go at that time to
move inside the keep
out sphere that's a invisible line with
a 200 meter radius
around the international space station
they'll need to make sure dragon is for
orbit safe or about six hours safe
if any of its thrusters were to fail for
some reason meaning it wouldn't move
inside the keep out sphere
during that time period
and after we reach waypoint one our next
destination will be waypoint 2
only 20 meters away from the
international space station and the
very last hold point before we move on
in
and after wave two there will be a go no
go pull
before our docking begins uh but that
should happen
very shortly after we reach waypoint two
and then
docking uh should occur just a few
minutes after that
yeah it'll take about five minutes to
get from that 20 meter hold point
waypoint two into docking
and the first call will look here just
before docking is chop
crew hands off point uh meaning that
they should not execute any maneuvers
for a dragon
pretty much exactly it means exactly
what it sounds like
and then we'll look for soft capture
soft capture call means that the soft
capture ring
has come in contact with the
international docking adapter
that ring will retract bring crew dragon
in
and then we will wait for 12 hooks to
drive to give us the hard capture
and once docking is complete uh it will
take a little bit
for um the a pass hatch to open and
dragon hatch to open but
open uh but that should occur you know
about an
hour maybe an hour an hour and a half
after docking has completed so there are
a few
um checks that they do have to still do
after docking is complete and confirmed
uh but shortly after that they'll be
able to uh
enter the station yeah those leak checks
ever important when we are talking about
the vacuum of space
so uh those will occur during that time
that crew dragon is docked the crew will
also get an opportunity to
duff or take off their suits uh get into
those more comfortable clothes again
before they float into their new home
for the next six months
but as you just heard we had a good
approach initiation
mid-course maneuver burn putting us on
proper trajectory to reach waypoint zero
the 400 meter
point away from the international space
station and the next
call coming up we will be listening for
a go no go
for waypoint zero in about five minutes
we are just about a
kilometer away from the international
space station so
getting closer and closer it's very slow
and steady
but almost there
oh
dragon spacex on the big loop the ground
is go
for approach zero we will be enabling
the maneuver shortly
expected maneuver start time is zero
three
zero nine utc reminder that dragon will
nominally continue
approach through waypoint one toward
waypoint two without stopping at
waypoint 1.
okay i can copy 0309 you will be
enabling the approach to zero shortly
and it will not stop and we see the
approach allowed now
station houston expect to start
monitoring dragon in approximately 25
minutes
25 minutes thank you
we've been getting some really
incredible views as dragon
gets closer and closer to the
international space station
just a minute ago we did see a live view
from
dragon looking at the space station uh
very i it was a little bright because of
the sun
there it is right there on your right
hand screen the international space
station
you could see how close they are
almost there on your left-hand screen is
the station looking
back at dragon
we heard a few calls there uh the crew
received the go from both the team here
in hawthorne and the team at mission
control houston
to proceed to waypoint zero and if
everything checks out they will also
move through waypoint zero which is 400
meters below station they'll pass
through waypoint
one as well and head on to waypoint two
and waypoint two is 20 meters away from
the space station
but we expect to reach way point zero
about nine minutes from now that's
709 pm pacific time so
standing by waiting for them to reach
that way point but we are getting
really close now we could be about an
hour away from docking
yeah we're just about 600 meters away
uh from the station right now
just about eight minutes from that uh go
no go
for waypoint one
just a reminder that this is all
autonomous dragon is completely flying
on its own
wow look at that view on the left hand
side
you can actually make out the nose cone
on top of dragon there wow
amazing views obviously the space
station is
in an orbital night time and soon in
just the next few minutes we should see
them
crossing that terminator line into
orbital daytime
but they're looking down right now space
station 262 statute miles over earth
as space station and dragon fly over
tanzania
[Music]
such a cool view and as a reminder we do
have the nose cone still attached to
dragon
on this version of dragon whereas
previously our cargo dragon
uh we actually deployed that nose cone
so now that we keep the nose cone
attached and this helps with
reusability efforts so that we don't
have to make a new one
don't have to install a new one when a
dragon returns
as we saw earlier the crew is inside
crew dragons suited up in their seats
strapped in
and they will be arriving at waypoint
zero and it looks like about
seven minutes
just such a cool view of
dragon from the station looking down
as is passing over earth they are moving
pretty quickly
uh now that you could see dragon uh
in view you can see how fast it is
moving against uh
the background of earth there and dragon
is approaching station now at half a
meter per second
a bit slower than we were seeing earlier
but that's because we are so much closer
to station now
we have to make every single maneuver
very fine-tuned very deliberate
you'll start to see things get brighter
as we mentioned as
space station and crew dragon enter an
orbital daytime
you'll be able to see a little bit of
the ocean below and then eventually
in just a few minutes both the vehicles
will be flying over madagascar
only about five four minutes away now
from
the arrival at waypoint
zero 400 meters away from the
international space station
and we're just under 500 meters away so
once we get to
waypoint zero we will be 400 meters away
[Music]
basically we'll just be passing through
waypoint zero through that uh 400 meter
point
and going uh continuing on
the next hold point would be way point
one
that is 220 meters away
they'll need to go to move inside the
keep out sphere a 200 meter radius
an invisible line around the
international space station
this is the same for every vehicle that
arrives and departs the station we
make sure that it is uh go to move
inside
and this means if dragon were to lose
control of its thrusters for some reason
it would be four orbit safe or six hours
before it crossed
into that 200 meter radius the keep out
sphere so
if everything looks good crew dragon can
move through waypoint one and up to
waypoint two
which will put us only 20 meters away
from the international space station
another view from crew dragon looking at
its future destination its future home
for the next six months the
international space station
even becoming more and more clearly
defined as they approach it as we said
earlier at about half a meter per second
you can see it shining brightly with the
sun
of beaming off of the international
space station
and our astronauts inside as we
mentioned suited up strapped in
monitoring but not controlling the
vehicle
crew dragon continues to fly
autonomously
and that is madagascar that both
vehicles are flying over right now
just as a reminder the crew is suited up
and they did perform
leak checks just as they did when they
got suited up and
ingressed the vehicle prior to liftoff
yesterday
and just a little look back at what
brought us to this point if you're just
joining us
crew dragon lifted off yesterday on a
falcon 9 rocket at 7 27
pm eastern time from kennedy space
center beginning their journey to the
international space station they
completed their first burn last night
the phase burn and then got a good
night's sleep
they had a phase of just burn this
morning added in there by dragon's
computers to make sure it was on the
right
trajectory to the space station and then
had the boost burn at 8 22 a.m pacific
time
about 45 minutes later we saw the close
coal elliptic burn
that maintained an orbit roughly 10
kilometers below station for dragon
we had a short out of plane burn
another one added in by the dragon cpu
computer system we moved on to the
transfer burn and then the final
coaliptic burn
those rounded out our five major burns
as part of the rendezvous phase for crew
dragon
once we reached the 30 meter 30
kilometer
distance from station we were out of
that rendezvous point
and then moved into the approach phase
that puts us at the approach
out of plane burn another short burn at
the dragon
computers executed we moved into
approach and docking and we saw that
approach initiation burn take place at 6
22
pm pacific time we also had a
short mid-course maneuver
and now we're just under a minute to
waypoint zero
looks like the station is zooming in on
dragon now you can
really clearly see dragon from the
station that looks amazing
yeah you can see that nose cone is open
just like you mentioned
that no cone protects the forward
bulkhead thrusters it also protects the
hatch that the astronauts will flow
through once they are attached to the
international space station
this is not the same hatch they entered
yesterday and it was on the launch pad
they won't uh that hatch won't be open
again until they splash down
about six months from now and that nose
cone only protects
um the gnc uh just through ascent
but in the vacuum of space we don't need
that protection so we have it deployed
so that we can expose the gnc so that it
can navigate
crew waiting patiently
less than a quarter of a mile away from
the international space station now
amazing that we're getting these views
inside the cabin during these
dynamic operations
it's really cool to see that
side-by-side
crew inside of the vehicle and then the
shot of the
dragon capsule so close to the
international space station
[Music]
dragon spacex on the big loop approach
zero has started and the trajectory has
converged on waypoint one
expect arrival at waypoint one at zero
three three four utc
okay copy zero three three four utc
arrival at way point one good burn
and we've conversion only one
so we've now passed waypoint zero
we're just a little under 24 minutes
away from
waypoint one which means we are inside
of that 400 meters
from station
as we mentioned uh we have passed
waypoint zero
they gave us a time of 7 34 p.m pacific
that we
should reach waypoint one but we do not
have to hold there
that uh waypoint one is approximately
220 meters away from the station and
dragon would be directly in front
of the node 2 forward port its docking
port
and if everything checks out we can move
through waypoint one will
have to have the go to move inside the
keep out sphere a 200 meter
invisible line uh radius around the
international space station
and that go confirms that if we were to
lose control of dragon's thrusters for
any reason
we would be four orbits or about six
hours safe
from moving inside that keep out sphere
so we'll need that go
for us to pass through waypoint one and
then
the next stop would be waypoint 2 about
20 meters from station
again we're uh about
15 minutes or so away from approaching
waypoint
one waypoint one will bring us
about 220 meters from the international
space station
and we don't have to hold there
um if we get the go we can continue
waypoint 2 which will bring us 20 meters
once we reach waypoint 2 we will pause
there
as we mentioned the crew is inside
they're seated up they won't have to
push any buttons or
fire any thrusters dragon is doing this
all on its own it's completely
autonomous
meaning the crew is just monitoring when
you see them looking at their screens
and waypoint two as you mentioned is 20
meters away from the international space
station
once we reach that point it'll take us
about five minutes
until we'll be looking for that soft
capture time
check it out we've got views of crew
dragon continuing its approach
to the international space station if
you just look to the left of the canada
arm there
you can see it uh continuing its way it
just
recently made it through waypoint zero
that 400 and
meters away or below the station
and we are next going to move through
waypoint
one that's 220 meters away directly in
front of the docking port the node 2
forward port
that's also where dragon docked during
demo one and demo two
we'll be looking for the go to move
inside the keep out sphere a 200
meter radius it's an invisible line
around the station
it's something that helps our flight
controllers monitor vehicles as they
approach
and even depart the international space
station
such a cool view seeing dragon with the
canada arm
up from the station and earth in the
background
and uh we used to use the canada arm to
capture dragon
uh before it was uh configured into
into this design this new crew dragon
design and it docks autonomously but
for a lot of our visiting vehicles we
have to use the canada arm too the
astronauts will reach out and grapple a
spacecraft
or grasp it once it gets close enough
and then flight controllers on the
ground will birth it or attach it to the
port on the international space station
but
dragon is fully autonomous the
astronauts are strapped in their seats
monitoring the mission awaiting the
milestones as we
move through waypoint one should be
coming up in just a couple of minutes
and continue our approach to waypoint
two twenty meters away from the space
station
and that last checkpoint before we move
in for docking
so
monitoring houston copies and we were
ready for that as well
[Music]
we are about 10 minutes away from
waypoint one
again that is where dragon will swing up
and out in front of the station
and that'll bring us about 220 meters
away from station
which will bring us to what we call the
docking access which essentially means
that we'll be right in front of the
docking port
and we we don't have to hold at waypoint
one
as long as we get that clear to move
inside the keep out sphere
that 200 and meter 200 meter radius
around the international space station
it's invisible
helps us monitor the arrival and
departure of visiting vehicles
this awesome view over the shoulder of
our commander and
pilot mike hawkins and victor glover
just monitoring the mission dragon is
flying autonomously
we are about 300 meters away
closing in on just about one meter per
second
so just about 80 meters to go until
waypoint one
amazing view of the international space
station that's from the cameras aboard
crew dragon
both getting a good look at each other
it's kind of cool to see them both
looking at each other as they approach
each other absolutely
and the crew on board also monitoring on
their three display panels there in
front of them
this is all autonomous so they really
don't have to do much
except for enjoy the ride but they do
get to
watch on those display panels uh
where they're at during this approach
here
you can also see the international space
station on that far right and the far
left panel
so they're getting really the same view
that we are right here
i'm sure they're pretty excited about
making it to their new home in space but
uh once they reach waypoint one as we
mentioned they don't have to stop
that'll be that 220 meter point
they'll move inside the keep out sphere
at 200 meters and then the next
stop will be waypoint two crew will be
20 meters away from the
international space station dragon will
focus on
aligning its docking system with the
international docking adapter
based on the attitude of the station
and it'll be about five minutes from
that waypoint to the 20 meter spot
until contact and capture
we'll be looking for that chop call
stands for crew hands off point two
meters before contact
and this means the crew is not
commanding the vehicle
they haven't been at this time but i
the vehicle can still have an abort at
that time however
it will not i've got good our prop data
on ssc 17
ssc 4 says our pup is not receiving
dragon 2 data from pcs
is that expected
copy that data
we can go ahead and fix that by cycling
it from the ground
or you can perform that task on the ssc
whichever is your preference
i'll let you guys do that thanks happy
we're putting in work now
astronaut kate rubins who's on the
international space station currently
the only american on the international
space station
uh she is joined by her two russian
cosmonaut friends
uh that is sergey rouzakov and sergey
kuzkov
i'll be welcoming four new crew members
to the orbiting laboratory
but she is monitoring the approach of
crew dragon she's also not commanding
the approach and as we mentioned she
won't be using the canadarm2 to reach
out and grapple the vehicle but
she was working to get some data and the
ground team is going to
recycle that data for her restart that
for her
as we were mentioning we were discussing
chop the crew hands-off point
the vehicle knows if it should abort so
at that point the crew would not be
commanding anything
however everything's still looking
healthy on dragon and on the
international space station
and this view that you're seeing here is
from the station from the node 2 docking
port
that dragon is currently approaching
this
is really our first view of both of them
in the same picture so
it gives you a good perspective on how
close they're getting to each other
yeah you can see in that left hand
bottom corner that is the station
and that white dot on your right
on the right side of your screen is
dragon slowly approaching
we're just under five minutes away from
way point one
or under 280 meters away
from the station
a little more of what we can look for
once we do get that go to move past way
point to the 20 meter point
of course we're going to reach waypoint
one first so we have a couple of steps
before this but
we will take about five minutes to get
in toward the station from
way point two and after that five
minutes we hear the chalk call
and we will be looking for soft capture
first
there are also rotary spring dampers
that will soften the contact
from crew dragon to the international
space station and that saw capture ring
will then begin retracting it'll retract
until sensors indicate it's time for
these hooks to drive and create a hard
capture and that will firmly secure
dragon to station the hook driving can
take about five minutes and the hard
mate of dragon to station can take about
three minutes
that means a full seal will be achieved
with 12
hard capture hooks
this is station onto a secret our pop
data on a safe one thanks
we are just about 30 minutes or so from
docking
with currently dragon approaching
waypoint one
waypoint one is approximately 220 meters
away from station
and you heard kate rubins who is
monitoring
this uh this mission and the arrival of
crew dragon
she discussed she used the term arpa
that stands for
rendezvous and proximity ops
program and so that is giving her
insight into
dragon's position and how it's moving in
toward the international space station
she'll have some work to do once dragon
arrives but
not until it gets there but once dragon
arrives the node 2
hatch where they are docking is
currently closed on the station side
dragon spacex on the big loop approach 1
and soft capture ring extension will
begin shortly
dragon will continue approach to
waypoint 2.
okay dragon copies soft capture angle
starts here
in the first one
crystal clear view of dragon as they get
the words
that everything is still looking good
with the systems and they will be moving
through way point one to waypoint two
and that they can expect that saw
capture ring we were discussing to
extend begin preparing them for docking
we're about 240 meters away so we're
just about a minute away from passing
through
way point one we're so
close that you could see the forward
bulkhead thrusters
on dragon there
it's basically those four uh
kind of circles that you see in the ring
where the nose cone is opened
on the top of dragon there
dragon continuing its slow and steady
approach to the international space
station
every single maneuver very deliberate we
have two vehicles this close in space
about 226 meters away
and what you're seeing on your screen on
your left hand screen is
the view from the international space
station
looking at dragon on your right hand
screen that is
a camera view dragon spacex on the big
loop expect reconfiguration of the c2 v2
return link shortly
okay
and we have passed waypoint one dragon
now about
213 meters away
from the international space station
[Music]
we also just heard the core speaking
with crew dragon to expect
a reconfiguration of c2v2 that stands
for common communications for visiting
vehicles
it establishes bi-directional
communications between crew dragon and
the international space station
so
so now we pass through waypoint once
we're about 10 minutes away from
waypoint 2.
once we approach waypoint 2 then we will
do a go no go pull for docking
so we're again around uh 30 minutes away
from docking here
depending on the timeline uh how uh
when we uh reach each one of these
points
we're on our way to waypoint 2 which
will bring us about 20 meters
in front of the space station
we moved right through waypoint 1 right
through the keep out sphere that 200
meter
invisible line around the international
space station
that helps flight controllers monitor
visiting spacecraft but we will have to
hold at waypoint 2
that 20 meter mark they'll conduct their
final checks
repair for arrival at the international
space station
a very clear view from crew dragon
that looks incredible
again this is a view looking at dragon
from station
from the node 2 forward port that dragon
will be
docking to today
sensational histogram 2 in step two of
one decimal one zero
four i've just commanded
[Music]
on our pop reference frame to
destination docking port and i see our
pop not receiving dragon 2 data
copy all cable checking
flight teams in mission control houston
continuing to check that our pop
rendezvous proximity operations program
station houston
we're going to reset our pop one more
time for you see if that works
thank you
they're resetting some of that data for
kate rubins a reminder she
is not commanding any part of dragon's
arrival
she is monitoring it though and so
looking for some of that data in that
program
[Music]
again we are on our way to waypoint 2
which will be 20 meters away
from the station once we reach waypoint
2 the vehicle will focus
on aligning its docking system with the
docking adapter
so preparing for docking
and there will be a go no go pull prior
to initiating that soft capture
approach here's that same view we were
looking at earlier and you can see even
how
much closer crew dragon has gotten in
just the short time since we
last received it having moved through
waypoint one since that time period
a little bit more about what kate rubins
will be doing once crew dragon docks
as we mentioned the no two hatch is
closed during the docking
the station side no two hatch kate
rubens will check for a leak and then
open it for access to the pressurized
mating adapter too
she'll also manually pressurize the
vestibule that's the area between the a
pass hatch which is on the station side
and the crude dragon hatch the apas
hatch is
what is currently exposed to the vacuum
of space
it also has a docking target on it that
allows dragon to
align itself with the port
once that pressurization is complete
okay rubens will be able to open the a
pass hatch to let some air in it's a
slow process
she'll be opening a valve specifically
on the a pass hatch to let that air in
and we'll hold for thermal stabilization
before we
do some leak checks in the vestibule we
want to make sure that
there aren't any fluctuating
temperatures
that are giving us misleading signals on
what the pressure is in the vestibule
we'll conduct the leak check for that
space between those two hatches
in the meantime the crew is doffing and
drying and stowing their suits during
that thermal stabilization and leak
check
they're stowing their equipment kate
will open the apas hatch and remove the
docking
target almost two hours post docking
these
these checks are taking place during
that time we will look for dragon's
hatch to be opened
dragon spacex on the big loop c2v2 link
reconfiguration is complete
the soft capture ring extension is also
complete
we are planning to hold momentarily at
waypoint 2
at that point we will be asking for your
input on lighting conditions
and your goal to proceed
do remember that your advisors are not
required to be down
until our final approach
okay dragon copies all and we'll be
holding momentarily at waypoint 2 and we
will
give you a good lighting check at that
point
so as you heard we are on our way to
waypoint 2
which will be 20 meters away from
station and we will hold
and do some checks do a go no go
hole to ensure that we are okay
to approach for docking and we did hear
confirmation that the soft
capture ring is extended and ready for
that docking
a few minutes ago we heard them
discussing c2v2
common communications for visiting
vehicles they said they would
reconfigure that system and just got
good confirmation
that it has been reconfigured that's
those bi-directional communications
between station and crew dragon
station houston on two for kate we're
still troubleshooting uh the
rpop issue you're having so we're coming
on board on ssc 17 and we'll try to fix
that
all right you are welcome to ssc 17 and
also
ssc for the main airpod computer
copy all we'll get it working
mission control houston checking back in
with
kate rubins aboard the station who is
working to monitor crew dragon's arrival
as we mentioned she is not uh commanding
anything that crew dragon is doing and
neither are the crew themselves
this is completely autonomous but she is
trying to monitor some of that data and
so
team members in mission control houston
are going to try and reconfigure the
rpop system rendezvous and proximity
operations program
from the ground
[Music]
you can see on your screen again this is
a view from
station from the node 2 port
that dragon will be talking to you see
the sunlight
hitting dragon as it gets
closer and closer
it's starting to get a little bit darker
outside
as well that's because the international
space station and crew dragon are
approaching an orbital night time they
are in daylight for 45 minutes and night
time for 45 minutes
circling the globe every 90 minutes
they're currently flying 260
statute miles over the pacific ocean
goodbye
you're looking at a live view of mission
control hawthorne here at spacex
headquarters in california
and if you notice we have lost video
temporarily of crew dragon as it's
approaching the international space
station but
that's really no surprise to us it's
something called a tdrs handover
tracking data and relay satellite system
uh teams on the ground are able to track
when the space station and crew dragon
will be moving in and out
of these handover periods and we expect
to regain video communications
with the space station very shortly
in the meantime it continues crew dragon
continues its approach to waypoint 2.
we have those views back already as you
mentioned jesse you can really see those
four
forward bulkhead thrusters the closer we
get
wow you can really see the detail on the
international space station
with how close we are
approaching way.2 which will be 20
meters
in front of the station that's why you
could see it so close up in that last
view
station houston on space ground two for
kate
thank you okay
so 17 is back up and running for you
we're working on four now
in addition let us know when your review
is complete and you are ready for
docking
copy and i saw soc working has given me
a good range of range and now i've got
another rpop that's not receiving dragon
q data from pcs
message on 17.
copy okay we'll take a look thanks for
the extra info
we've now reached waypoint two so we are
holding this position
i'm going to do some so you have a good
uh dragon docking system view
on ssc 17 for the dragon docking
streaming monitor and i have a good out
of the window view so i am comfortable
and my review is complete
copy all thank you
great news from kate rubin she has the
data she's looking for and a great view
of crew dragon out the window as well
so she's given her go for them to depart
waypoint two
and move into the international space
station as a reminder we moved directly
through waypoint
one which put us directly in front of
the docking port you can see it right
here
that's the node two forward port where
dragon docked during demo one
and demo two
spacex on the big loop the ground is go
for approach two
at this point please confirm that the
lighting conditions are acceptable to
proceed and
let us know if you are go for approach 2
and docking
okay spacex this is dragon on the big
loop
so the lighting is actually getting
worse we do have a view
of the idea but we do not have a view of
the docking target
[Music]
and dragon spacex we copy we are six
minutes from sunset would you like to
hold for those six minutes or do you
feel comfortable proceeding
uh we'll go ahead and hold for those six
minutes if we can
we copy hold
crew dragon crew has opted to hold at
waypoint 2 for the time being
so they can get some better views of the
uh the docking port the docking target
on that a pass hatch we were discussing
that's on the international space
station
so they can hold here and that will give
them the opportunity for
sunset to come over both the
international space station and crew
dragon
there won't be any odd shadows and they
should have better visibility
of course the crew themselves are not
making this maneuver in toward the
international space station it is
autonomous
crew dragon will be doing it by itself
but we want the crew to be able to
see the docking target so that they can
properly monitor
as the vehicle continues to make its
approach to node 2.
and the ground is go for docking but we
are just waiting
for us to get a little bit more light so
that
dragon can actually see where it is
going to autonomously dock
uh see the target on node 2
as it approaches so it can make that
soft capture accurately
we're in another one of those satellite
handovers we just discussed as well we
should get video communications oh
right there coming back and
you